hello everyone I'm most peculiar thing
happened today a couple of days ago I
gave an interview for the local
newspapers and they asked me a couple of
things about my channel and among other
things I said that out of all the chest
channels my my channel receives the most
most views in the world per month and
this is a any information that's
available to everyone you can you can
check all the statistics regarding any
YouTube channel for example in
socialblade but when they decided to
publish this article they left out in
the title of this article the part that
it's a chess channel they just wrote
that I have the most use of any YouTube
channel in the world so this was quite
disturbing but even more disturbing was
the fact that every news portal in
Croatia just copy pasted this article
and just you know planted it on their
own 4 news portal so now every news
portal in Croatia is basically saying I
have the biggest YouTube channel in the
world a channel with the most views so
that's that's pretty disturbing fact as
if you even consider for a second you
know if you think that a chess channel
can have most views out of any channel
in the world that's you know either
either that's either you really don't
know what you're talking about or or
chest really does have a bright future
but regardless you know just just wanted
to let you know how things are done in
Croatia
about the game I decided to show another
game from the 1959 candidates this time
it's Paul Banco playing against Michael
Dahl and the poll Banco had a pretty
terrible score throughout his life
against Michael Dahl
all I know the result was a to install
one win Banco and three draws so is this
one of the games were banco beat style
well we'll just have to see and also the
game features one move that doesn't
really make sense and a lot of people
said this about banco then when that
when he faced it all that he always
always got nervous so banco goes for
Knight to f3 the reti opening and star
plays f5 he counter is already with the
Dutch with the Dutch variation g3
a knight to f6 g2g 6c for Bishop to g7
both sides developing Knight to c3
castles castles d6 d4 Knight to c6 d5
and Knight to a5 by tal Queen to d3 and
c5 and here
White has a couple of options to
consider probably the best idea is to
push b3 develop a Bishop to b2 and just
continue developing a sharper line will
be something like efore but if you go
into that you really have to know what
you're doing if Knight captures Knight
captures pawn captures and Queen
captures like yes this extra tempo with
Bishop to a5 and after you move the
Queen somewhere as you do have to
protect the c4 pawn queen to e2 not
Bishop to g4 is coming and now black has
this threat of capturing onion on f3 and
after Bishop captures simply capture the
pawn with the night and c4 and if the
Queen captures it then rook will
recapture the bishop on f3 or if you
play something like h3 doesn't really
matter it's the same idea Bishop
captures Bishop captures and Knight
captures on c4 now either you will
capture and black captures on f3 or you
will do something else
let's they move the Bishop to g4 and
then black will simply protected the
knight would be 5 so after this the c5
move like I said b3 probably the best
option but the bank will decide to go
for Knight to g5 and there is a really
no there's really no reason to put the
knight on d5
ok you can just leave it there on g5 you
know it's not like Todd will ever push
h6 to weaken his Kings position but
there was a better move to play here a 6
doll ignores the night and he continues
on the Queen side he wants to push b5 we
have rook to be 1 now comes work to be 8
Bishop to d2 and Queen to e8 now also
preparing to put b5 notice yes the
knight is undefended on a5 but this
night doesn't really have any good
discoveries so b3 we have B 5 vital a3
and now Knight to g4 Knight back to f3
so now then I
served its purpose on g5 and be be
captors on c4 be captures on c4 and rook
to b3 now Benko captures it might
capture some b3 and rook to be one and
here a lot of players would probably
think okay my knight is attacked he does
have this Bishop on d2 I have a very
strong bishop on g7 so probably I'm
gonna capture the bishop on D to get rid
of his own a dark square bishop I don't
want anything to oppose my strong dark
square Bishop on g7 so probably for many
players Knight captures on d2 would be
an automatic but stop place nice to d4
as this is the more poisonous move and
here align that white pretty much has to
go for is is h3 but after playing h3 you
have to take into consideration a five
by black so now if you capture the night
you get E for attacking the knight and
the Queen so after D captures on e6 on
Poisson you get Knight captures on f3
Queen captures and now getting the night
out of the way in 95 while attacking the
Queen Queen moves and now Bishop
captures on e6 and everything everything
is holding White is perfectly fine here
okay there's a double attack on the c-4
point you can simply play 95 defended
and all is well but after this night to
d4 Benko played III he wants to get rid
of that knight on d4 and okay it's all
plays Knight captures on f3 we have
Bishop captures and now the other night
comes to a 525 attacking the c4 pawn the
Queen and the bishop on f3 we have Queen
to e2 the only square which defends the
bishop and the pawn on c4 and now comes
Knight captures on f3
Queen captures on f3 and now tau manages
to push a 5 and calf I mean by pushing
g5 tau created a pretty massive center
here and white would definitely enjoy
breaking that center with 2d characters
a nice example Sun but if you play this
after Bishop captures an e6 there is no
good way to to really protect the c4
pawn queen tv2 Queen to f7 and the too
much pressure would amount on that c4
pawn so after this if I move
the d1 was played here van ho wants to
go for Queen to afford to exchange
Queens
efore by tall quaint wait for now
and Queen to e7 tall avoids the trade of
Queens Queen to c6 and we have f4 now by
tau and this was one and this f4 move
was actually the only move in the
position that is that is actually good
for black and continuous black and
allows black to continue with any sort
of counter play the idea of course
behind the four it's a very tactical
move you have to you have to consider it
captures on f/4g captors on f4 a lot of
moves to consider and of course white is
threatening not to develop the bishop to
h3 what would happen if you play it
captures on a for this loses the game
immediately due to e3 now if you capture
with the bishop you lose the piece the
Bishop captures on c3 and if for some
reason you decide to play F captures
then comes Bishop captures Bishop
captures Queen captures would check you
have to move
kingi to but now comes Queen e2 check
King moves and now Bishop to h1 and a
bishop to h3 and there is no defense
against checkmate rock blocks but now
Queen to f3 this is check rook rook has
to block and Queen captures on g2 this
is checkmate
so after this f4 move the best idea
would be to play GTA actors on f4 but
again it's a very complicated game that
will always favor black Queen Bishop to
h3 first with the idea of going Queen to
h4 followed by Queen to g4 end and you
know delivering checkmate so the only
the only real defense here is Queen to
a4 going back to d1 to cover the g4
square after g5 now now black will try
to open up the position
Queen to be one and now Queen to e8 with
the threat G captures on a four fold by
Queen to g6
and again a checkmate on g2 so f5 not
allowing this Bishop captures and after
Queen to e2 Bishop simply comes back to
h3 and now you can see that there is
simply no way no way white can stop the
attack
to f3 queen is coming to h5 it's all
over
so after this f4 move banco tried one
last idea that was interesting he tried
a rook to b8 was so when the bishop is
developed he can immediately exchange
rooks Tao did play Bishop page 3 now
comes rock captures Queen captures and
now he captures on f4 and here Tao
played Queen to b8 this is again the
only move that gives tall the
opportunity to strike and not only that
it's actually the winning move as there
is no more defense the threat is Bishop
captures on c3 Bishop captures and Queen
to be one will be checkmate after the
Bishop blocks with Bishop to e1 and here
you can try to block for example with
tonight to b5 simply giving up a piece
but white doesn't have any counter play
here so in the game after this going to
be it move banco tried Knight to e2 but
tal seemed to place Queen to be one
check and it was in this position that
banco resigned but it's a very
interesting why did banco resign for
example it doesn't matter if check is
blocked by the knight or by the bishop
let's say 9 2 c1 here you have the
opportunity you're playing with towels
pieces beat bowl banco so you know give
it a couple of seconds pause the video
and try to find a winning move for black
as it's very interesting and it's very
easy to blunder so for those of you who
were able to solve this congratulations
you're a great player and for those of
you who found the wrong move the wrong
idea would be something like going to
Bishop to b2 like attacking the paint
piece and of course it seems winning but
this is actually a complete draw because
the Queen can deliver checkmate on h8 on
e 8 and now it's a perpetual check you
have to move kingi 727 and now you have
to go back to g8 allowing perpetual
checks if you go to h6
you're getting checkmated f5 this is
check from the bishop King gauge 5 and
now Queen to h4 this would be checkmate
and this would be a terrible way to end
the game so yeah
after this queen-to-be one move he
resigned because after this night the
see to the actual idea is Queen to c2
and now there is no there is no turning
back after you can give a couple of I
want I want check after Bishop blocks
with Bishop to f8 there's no Queen e6
check Bishop is blocking that so after a
bishop to e1 you don't want to meet
Queen D one with check simply Queen
captures on c4 and now there is no
defense against Queen to f1 checkmate
whatever black plays its Queen f1
checkmate he can give a couple of pieces
before that but yeah so after this Queen
to be one move
tal Riza I'm just kidding Paul Banco
resigned the game and this wonderful
victory was achieved which in the end
was one of the games that allowed tall
to win the 1959 candidates tournament so
yeah I might also show that one win
against tau by Paul Banco that was I
believe in 1962 candidates tournament so
yeah maybe I will show that one as well
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank John Anthony
tables ADM music Michael Hildebrand
William Avery
Julian Olinsky and Samuel bekommen
Benkelman for your contribution to my
channel think a lot I really appreciate
it as usual if you checked all my
previous videos here and I will be
uploading your Q&A video today so
there's there were really a lot of
questions a lot of them were the same so
I eliminated the same questions so if
anyone asks you know about how I started
the channel I will only use one question
I will not answer all of them because
even without that there are simply a lot
of questions so yeah I thank you all and
I'll see you soon